now it is ninth year behind the Penguin's bench
of course he won a cup in his first two years in
Pittsburgh it is Shen kaan and neighbors against
gel Crosby and Russ and cleaner plays than we
saw on Thursday yeah much better better support
whether it's you know skating to the open Ice to
be available or just executing with a good flat
pass it's look much we now it's O Conor he comes
in shoots it on goal and a save by Bennington
on drew a Conor who's out of dness now the puck
loose another shot and that goes high off the
Stick of Bim zahora turn over and got the blues
out of their Zone in the and the faceof one by
Thomas that slides back to Center Ice promis
the Blue's best Faceoff man early on over 55% he
comes back in now for CYO gets it to S he pulls
up backhander rebound Thomas wide open S with
it shoots he scores saw and the blows lead one
nothing we talked about that earlier get the lead
the first time they've had it all season they're
pursuing pucks very well as a fiveman group they
stay with it that's the biggest thing they don't
give up on any play here it bounces around finally
come to Brandon side but I think that's the key
right there they're they're like dogs on a bow
just hungry down there for that puck dangerous
guys on the ice big opportunity there big save
now Russ with it shoots it that's Block in the
back of the gold gel tied up by cre and now
Russ number 17 has it again Letang for rust
snaps a shot that's blocked by KW comes back to
the line fand on Blues get it and SS Off to the
Races he's going to break in the CLA and a save
by jar on sod and the Penguin net has come free
on that play look at this just barely going five
hole there leang crashes it pressure by the blues
pyou back for KR Krug lets it Go rebound Shan
Rob by jari what a chance there he's lost his
goal stick gets it back though and now Thomas
feeds it back to kyou couple of good looks in
the power play kyou to Thomas right in back door
feed and crew tipped it just wide and then Shen
in there against lat there's a three men on it
trying to FY it three 25 to go in the power play
now KW across to Thomas Thomas to the line gr to
cyu and he waits good looking power play here for
the blues B level eight goal to the goal line
to Shen lost it and out of the box Mulin has a
break in alone with seven to go in the period
shoots he scores and Mulin is tied with 3.7
left then the puck just bounces over Tory gr stick
and unfortunately the timing is right to Gin Malin
who comes in Waits Waits Waits a very experienced
goal scorer he's waiting for Jordan Bennington to
just move give him a little bit of something and
he goes right above the pad under the arm and the
race what just happen and go create the rest of
the period by the way that go by saw the first
first period goal the blues have scored this year
so underway here in the second period it is kyus
and Thomas for the blues against the Crosby
unit Crosby gets in now for Russ back to the
cage here's Crosby shooting one and that goes High
over the goal and kept Alive by Chris matang and
now for gensel the first to Ross that pass back of
the goal intended for Crosby here's Paro long feed
that Springs Thomas Thomas to saw in the clear
and a save by jar anding to Center one Ohad nearly
had another one as the blues get a great chance
now Cory trying to get away from the checking of
Raquel Shen for fa fre on two break here for the
blues the capan makes a move in on goal kaan to
neighbors he scores what a play and Jake neighbors
is given the boers a two to one lead we bring
this back into the Blue Zone Justin bu you just
finished talking about him he gets up makes that
pass out wide drives through the middle of the
ice what happens there is Ru Weedle has to respect
Justin faul going to the front of the net and then
of course casber Captain just dancing out here on
Saturday night finds Jake neighbors who we just
talked about getting to the blue paint be hungry
to score goals and Jeff Carter that bounces into
the Zone Neo comes in against Caro that's slammed
around and a good read by Eric Carlson to keep
it alive for Pittsburgh deep slot P it fires it
blocked I think by Paro and the blue is away and
with with numbers again now into sunfit to the net
Toro what a save by jar on torup Cho and now Paro
with it shoots he scores oh thank you thank you
thank you but here's another really well executed
three on two TKO gets in there but nobody gives
up on the play hold Breo here drops the hammer
and not only is this a great shot it goes right
off the top shelf where you keep the peanut butter
John Great Net front presence to by Oscar sunquist
first time this year the blues take a lead into
the third period and underway with the third it
is kyus s and Thomas for the blues Here Comes Kyu
chap Thomas follows up now to saw to backhander
and a save made by jar good chance there right off
the bat drao what a great skater he is and here he
comes trying to go Coast to Coast like butter on
toast and a shot on goal and a save there by jar
and the penguins come back and Riley Smith leaves
it Rael backhander what a save by bton on Smith
maybe his best tonight there's CPP in one-onone he
comes in and he can't dangle around Chris L tang
and the Penguins counter gensel leads it here
comes Eric Carlson to the net for gensel and
a right patch save by Bennington what a read and
what a save and the Blues play it off the boards
and back to Center and a two on one now to sad
with Thomas shoots he scores s his second that's
4-1 well the blues go back the other way
great team speed here capitalizing cury C
and he and have had a great game tonight
Brandon o Conor and now for Eller here
kandal with a heavy hit on o Conor in
the near corner and O Conor back to the
skates now it comes in front wrap around and they
score and that's so Horna who's been dangerous all
night called up for the miners and he makes it 4-2
we get a good look here scell goes in for the hit
loses his stick on the play that allows Pittsburgh
to get control of the puck there and then torna
right in tight gets it up high kind of bounces
around a little bit get a good look at it from up
above sort of a bad break off the skates of blood
you know challenge by the blues but obviously you
can't challenge it but they argue with the referee
jar by the way back in goal for now two 10 to go
and the p was down to the Zone with lank and then
Eller for lank that shot blocked by dorenko and
Shen has a break away here he comes and it's Sav
by jar there's Shen on a clearcut break there what
a block though by Tor chro he's feeling it right
now but that's exactly why you block those shots
give your team a chance to win the game and that
one there Shaner got a a goal scoring opportunity
Paro that pass off some skates at Center doubled
up by Toro he comes in and takes ahead and eats
the buck with 90 seconds left in regulation
corenko now for shin in front and what a save
by jar uncap it they needed big performances
and they got him and the Blues win the face
off and that's going to do it so a great end to
the home stand as the Blues win 42 is the final